[Music]
[Applause]
so welcome again on behalf of the kitty
Anderson Youth Science Center where our
mission is to empower youth to change
our world through science so the kitty
Anderson Youth Science Center we work
with the intersection of social justice
and science so again welcome the first
born Mexican born citizen to ever win
the Nobel Prize in Chemistry so Mario do
you want to give everyone a little bit
of your background so they know who you
are
okay I'll just spend a few minutes make
sure because we professor sometimes tend
to talk for hours what stopped me in a
few minutes I was born in Mexico City
and went to elementary school like all
children Harold all sort of classes
including some science classes that were
very boring at that time because they
consisted mostly of just memorizing but
somehow or other when I was still very
young 10 11 years old I liked to read so
I started to read some biographies of
scientists and came fascinated with that
then I got my parents were very nice
with me at that time and they gave me a
chemistry set to do experiments and I
was fascinated actually doing science
and doing experiments rather than just
memorizing issues and I remember I also
got a toy a microscope and discovered in
from I had some lettuce that I let rot
in water and when it started to smell I
was able to take a little drop of that
water and I was fascinating because
fascinated because with a microscope you
could see a different world
it's not visible to your naked eyes lots
of little creatures we know now the fair
emission and amoeba and all sorts of
things and so at that point I decided I
wanted to become a scientist I thought
you could only do that that's a hobby
that will be my hobby I later realized
you could actually earn a living being a
scientist and of course I decided I
remained a scientist so I continued with
my interests basically reading and doing
experiments on my own then went to
college in Mexico I studied Chemical
Engineering because I like chemistry and
chemical engineering was very much
connected with the sort of things I was
interested in and it was many years ago
the century imagine but it was a
reasonably good school except that I
didn't get very up-to-date education at
that time modern science was not really
part of Chemical Engineering as it is
now what I learned a lot it was a good
education but then I decided at that
time I wanted to change from engineering
to basic science so first type I was
able to get a scholarship and went to
Europe I spent almost two years in
Germany and then in France getting a
master's degree and so on but I realized
what I really wanted was to this change
from engineering to science was not easy
to carry out in Europe and I made the
right decision and did manage to get a
scholarship to story in the United
States so I went to Berkeley because
education there was at that time much
more flexible the Europeans have now
tried to change in that direction
because here in the US when you go to
you get you may get a PhD you become a
good friend of your mentor okay and you
talk by first names and whatnot and then
and you become involved with your mentor
and with a group of students that will
research there so that was great the
great
perience in germany at that time there
now changing and so on but it was only
her professor that you could only meet
occasionally and you would have to sit
down and he was sitting on a higher
chair and so on who tells you story
these books next year come and see me
and see what you've learned okay so that
doesn't work for me very well but in the
United States was great because I
learned and I learned a lot of science
but it was my passion to do research to
experiments finding new things and you
know if the some of you here in a
science museum how satisfying it is if
you do things and you see that they work
experience that they work but it's even
more fascinating when you're working
like I was with a very well-known mentor
and you things that are new that you're
the first one in this planet that finds
out in my case it was some chemical
lasers how some reactions take place and
so on so I was very happy but it was
very hard work but I did finish my PhD
at Berkeley
doing very basic science and then with a
colleague that I had met before that was
also doing very basic science his name
was sherry Rowland decided to work with
him and we both decided to do something
more applied something where we could
apply this fundamental science perhaps
so that it would have some impact on
society and we chose just to work on out
of curiosity to pick up an example of
something that was new in the atmosphere
we were not almost very excited at that
time so we chose a problem so we would
learn about it the problem that we chose
is what happens to certain industrial
chemicals that were just being developed
that they are not natural you heard a
very nice presentation as you as before
we were talking that describe what went
on and then afterwards but essentially
we realize that these chemicals we
didn't know that that they would have a
very strong environmental impact
because they would affect the ozone
layer which is up there in the
stratosphere protects us all from
ultraviolet radiation that causes among
other things
skin cancer okay so we certainly realize
that we had a big problem that was not
we had the science but first the science
had to be checked by our colleagues and
then we had a big challenge of trying to
convince society to do something about
it but we managed because we had friends
in the scientific community other
atmospheric scientists that really
realized that it was indeed a serious
problem and they helped us but then we
we decided we have to communicate this
to society that was a challenge we
didn't know how to do that but we
learned we communicated with decision
makers in government first Congress man
and so on and then eventually we were
able to get even to heads of state but
together with some other friends that
were diplomats and so on and that's how
this international agreement the
Montreal Protocol came about and it was
that was years later we made this
discoveries
early 1970s but it was only until 1985
that this international agreement was
agreed upon and by that time the
Antarctic ozone hole of course was
already discovered that it was realized
wow that's a very large something that
is happening and we were trying to go
miss people that's not natural it's
something that we humans are causing and
the science became very clear we could
establish that very well with colleagues
that were able to measure what was the
cause of this phenomenon where you know
in the Antarctic stratosphere a certain
altitude were also known it's normally
most abundant in the springtime as in
not at night which lasts many months but
during the springtime when the day
begins to come up which again takes
several months to before the night comes
again
at that time with the light and we later
found out exactly why and so on also
started to disappear at those altitudes
99 percent of the ozone was going away
in a matter of weeks okay so it was a
very spectacular effect that in some
sense it helped us to convince the world
that something was happening fortunately
not many people live under the Antarctic
ozone hole but in the southern countries
Chile and Argentina and so on people are
indeed affected and it's even in
Australia and so on so it was very clear
that it was an important problem and
anyhow we succeeded not just we but we
were able to work together with the rest
of the first a scientific community
protein also people in government and
industries we were very closely to the
industries that were manufacturing these
chemicals that initially of course
didn't want to do anything but
afterwards when we convinced them that
the science was correct they very
creatively came up with other chemicals
that would not affect the ozone layer so
in a nutshell the mantra protocol is a
very big success because it's the first
time that we have a truly global problem
why global because it doesn't matter who
are you manufacturer for you emit these
chemicals they mix all over the planet
and they affect this layer that protects
all over the planet
so unless all the countries were
together you're not sure you're going to
be able to solve it but now we did it
and the ozone layer is recovering hasn't
recovered yet but we know why because
the CFCs remain in the atmosphere for
many decades so we're still seeing the
effects what was emitted last century
but it's very clearly recovering so that
that's essentially why we're sort of
very happy we got also a Nobel Prize
which is extremely rewarding work but
it's a big responsibility because we
realized that having a Nobel Prize we
have access to different layers if you
want you
in policy issues all the way to heads of
state and we are trying to use what we
learned to deal with climate change
that's another very big issue I could
keep talking for hours about that you
heard a little bit and we haven't done
that yet we in a big summary finally
after many years we have a similar
international agreement which is the the
Paris Accord which practically all the
heads of state in the planet agree that
we have to follow that to solve the
problem there is one exception only one
head of state doesn't agree you know who
I'm talking about wrong and that's for
irrational reasons we consider that to
be a very high Eva sponsibility to
future generations so we're going to do
something about it
but we think this is temporary because
many other groups industries California
Massachusetts we need majors of all the
big city we're all working together and
the bottom line is when we work together
and when we have something that we can
justify with science and we can do it
very clearly then we know that the
problem can be solved because we have
done it before but we have to work very
hard so I invite all of you to keep
working hard
for the benefit of everybody in summary
that
[Music]
so you talked a lot about working with
politicians students people from
different countries just in general you
talk a lot about teamwork right do you
see yourself as a change maker and what
is a change maker to you change maker is
when you find something we were in some
sense in reaching that ball when we
realize that humans were affecting in
this case a global environment because
we already knew that they were
environmental issues you're polluting
rivers and so on and so forth but a
change makers when we found that humans
are really changing the functioning of
the entire planet of course later that
became much clearer there are now
scientific papers and groups that are
trying to find out where other things
are changing
globally there is a group that were a
big part of them to some extent writing
some papers where they talk about
so-called planet boundaries why are we
doing to the entire planet that this
worship we're changing the nitrogen and
phosphorus cycles for example we're
acidifying the oceans climate change is
still one of the largest if not the
largest rate that we have but another
very worrisome part those of you that
like biology for example or or ecology
is the the loss of species okay we're
losing we are approaching a mass
extinction of biological species but
they are not disappearing naturally they
are disappearing because we humans are
doing a lot of deforestation and using a
lot of land for agriculture so the point
is where you should be much more careful
now because those are very important
components of ecology that it will be
very important for future generations to
make sure that we don't deplete all the
natural resources that we have to count
on for our survival and for to achieve a
reasonable standard of living
thank you so here at the Kitty Anderson
use Science Center we have a lot of
youth and we have a lot of young adults
that work here so with all this work
that you did did you have a mentor and
how important is mentorships between
young people and adults I think it's
it's very important of course the main
mentor I have I didn't have time to
explain that anymore but that was in my
PhD doing research it was George
Pimentel was his name he wrote a number
of takes what he made some movies also
about explaining science to the public
but I became very good friends and so
that was a very important relationship
if you were at that time not connected
with environmental issues but just with
learning science he was passionate about
science and of course I was passionate
about science as a graduate students
before that in Mexico and college many
of my teachers were not particularly
good because at that time the University
of Mexico was just growing the National
University now it's become more like
American European universities where the
professors do research but at a time in
chemical engineering some of them were
just working in industry maybe not
necessarily doing science or engineering
and they lectured just a little bit as a
hobby and I never realized not all of
them understood science very well okay
but a few of them were magnificent those
were also my mentors I became friends
and so on and it as I go back in time in
high school I've had a couple of also
very good teachers but not very many and
that's what we were trying to change
because we realize that the way science
is taught in schools has to change it's
already changing with what we call
active learning namely we don't just
expect that the teacher will tell the
students what science is all about and
expecting to memorize it but the the
actually you get the students to do
science to do experience and then
discuss it among them sir
and then form groups and then you
discuss it with the teacher and you do
actual experiments you go and plant
seeds and see how plants grow as animals
grow and in that way you also learn to
appreciate nature it's not just the
science but you develop the values
working together with other students
also you also develop this very
important component of the solutions
we're talking about this working
together we all end up winning that's
very clear there always somebody that
tries to cheat and so on but if you can
avoid that we can do much better when we
do it together and that's what we're
trying to to change starting in
elementary school but going all the way
to college levels so sounds like
education is key and at the KYC we do a
lot of active learning hands-on
activities but there are still barriers
when it comes to doing this kind of
scientific work so what's it like being
Mexican working in a white dominated
field for me it turns out since I grew
up in Mexico and went to college in
Mexico I was lucky in the sense that
when I joined the research group at
Berkeley many students were foreigners
to begin with so if it was sort of
natural that you didn't have to be a
u.s. born person to fit okay what I
later of course realized and is learning
about our society functions that can be
a very big barrier in the same way that
it is let me give you an example which
is sort of connected for that the role
of women okay when I was in in in in
Mexico studying engineering we had just
a handful of women studying engineering
as well women normally they studied
perhaps form a suitable chemistry or so
things have changed now what the best
example is at the MIT they got very well
potato pie
years in this aspect and so the fact is
that now you have as many women as men
as male engineers that's fascinating but
there's one more very interesting aspect
this is already a decade ago or so at
MIT they realized we already done the
right thing with students but something
is wrong because practically all the
managers the president the Chancellor
they were all male something is wrong so
they decided to actively change it the
next president was a woman a very nice
and very efficient president of MIT and
so nowadays half of the leaders are
women as well so you have to actively
realize that there's a problem and
change that not just starting and with
the students but at all levels okay
that's what is still missing in society
we need to do that in with our
politicians and so on and we know that
there are still difference in salaries
so we have to keep working with it
but in terms of minorities I better
don't talk a lot because you know that
we do have a problem with the central
government that is terrible okay and so
that I think that poor misunderstanding
and it has to do in the in the running
it really has to do with ignorance I've
got to tell you something but there's no
press around I hope it turns out this is
sort of known by by Mexicans that
President Trump you know he's a
businessman so some years before he ran
for president one of his business
expansions had to do with building a
resort in Mexico in Baja California but
it was in a place that was sort of
government controlled because you wanted
to protect by diversity where so they
did not allow him to build his
his project and he was very upset so I
think that explains in part
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I see that a few hands already up so
we can get to a question answer but
before I do that I forgot to do
something because I'm a little nervous
up here but I have five brothers and
brothers well my brothers and I'm the
oldest and only girl and so we're always
like competing to see who's like the
coolest kid or whatever and so one of my
brothers was just named like one of the
best baseball players in Minnesota cool
whatever and then my other brother is
graduating this June he's the first one
ever I'm a mom Sider graduated college
so that's cool too but I'm up here with
Mario Molina and I think that's cool so
Mario have you ever taken a selfie with
this many young people before have you
ever taken a selfie with this many young
people before I wouldn't know how but go
ahead and then we can get to the Q&A so
this is how you do it okay how would he
do it okay so we're gonna face this way
okay and then everybody's gonna be in
the background stand up get close you
know Wow
oh this way okay and so do you see how
every whoa I can see everybody Wow get
ready we're gonna count in Spanish okay
una all right very selfie my nose and
all of you
all right so how many of you have used
this little cube thing before
all right so for those of you that
haven't it's a microphone and so you
just put it up to you and it works as a
microphone so it's really cool science
so I'm gonna throw it to someone ask
your question and then we're just gonna
have you answer it and then keep going
sound good okay all right um I play
softball for 14 years but I this is
different there you go you said that
slowly the ozone layer is the hole in
the ozone layer is repairing how exactly
is it repaired
did I get the questions that's over the
ozone layer is okay you said slowly the
hole in the ozone layers repairing how
exactly is it repairing itself it's okay
because we can measure that this part of
the way the science works we know that
something was happening to it not when
we first started suggesting that it that
these chemicals were affected but then
measurements from satellites from at
that time they were balloon measurements
okay do you send a balloon up filled
with helium all the way up to 40 50
kilometers altitude and they were doing
measurements later in Antarctica you
know that that was not in Antarctica so
the first set of measurements were in
other parts of the planet but then if
you have the story also had been
measured before mostly by not by
chemists but what people in meteorology
and we call Earth Sciences because they
wanted to understand how the
stratosphere functions and also is made
at the tropics and then moves to higher
latitudes so it was very interesting to
measure also used to see how things move
so they were sort of annoyed that we
chemists then came along I say hey
something's happening to it
over Antarctica it's very interesting
how it was measured because balloons are
difficult it's difficult to do that but
you could measure ocean from the ground
because the ultraviolet radiation that
destroys our DNA makes it to this
instrument so you can measure it from
the ground what does were not very easy
experiments if you want to measure it in
the morning what you have to do get up
early have breakfast and do what over
Antarctica you have to spend the night
there and that's several months okay
three or four months
so if spend the night then you were up
to suddenly have time for breakfast but
then you start measuring and the first
few weeks that's when the ozone hole
appeared and it turns out that then
later to make sure that we understood
what was happening you could measure it
with an airplane the airplane could not
take off from Antarctica because there
are no good Airport there so it took off
from Punta Arenas which is the southern
tip of Chile in South America and the
airplane I mentioned that because sort
of fun it's called an ear - it's an
airplane poor you have only one pilot
but it's designed to fly at very high
altitudes but it was not designed for us
scientists it was the plane that was
designed to spy over Russia okay and one
of them was shot down at some point in
time I the pilot was trapped in Russia
it was a big scandal but that was what
the Soviet Union was there so we used
the same airplane used to spy over
Russia to spy over Antarctica and it
worked extremely well one pilot all
sorts of instruments that had to
function on the road and it became very
very clear from those measurements that
people was indeed the CFCs that were
causing the the ozone hole but it's all
based on measurements okay that's the
way science works it's not that you
think or you we call that evidence based
science and you have to be able to
reproduce your findings so the
measurement was carried out not just
once but many times
central and so forth that's a nature of
science you're skeptic you don't believe
in something until evidence shows that
it's it's actually happening all right
next question where's the cubic erodible
okay
hi I'm it here and my question is what
did you do with your prize money what
did you do with your prize money I used
the more than half something almost two
thirds to set up some scholarships one
of them giving a donation to MIT so it's
a scholarship that you get in this case
students of our own origin Latin
American students because they were very
few to do the various studies ok and the
other part was to the Mexican government
to do to have some fellowships so that's
still working so so that
one of your most recent projects you've
been working on the brakes I'm working
on now are I switched I can't been doing
a lot of science at MIT having a group
of students doing research and we
learned a lot first of all the
stratosphere of explaining the ozone
hole and so on but then we switch to air
quality and we'll be lost on air quality
stories for example in Mexico City we
work at a Mexican city was the most
polluted city in the planet for a while
but then we were able with with MIT help
and with him working with the Mexican
government to improve that quite
dramatically just like Los Angeles okay
but later I'm after getting the Nobel
Prize I decided I had to change somewhat
because you get this responsibility that
you realize you can access people at
higher levels so I decided to have this
story Center in Mexico in which we would
do more science policy projects and
that's the sort of thing I've been doing
in Mexico with energy issues as well as
environmental issues air quality but
also climate change Mexico was sort of a
leader among developing countries in
setting up the something like the Paris
agreement okay
but also keep working in the United
States I teach it in San Diego and there
I'm more involved with collaborating
with my research colleagues finding out
that how particles that come out of the
ocean form you know particles and also
are the two things that that you're
going to have with poor air quality so
we have to understand how they're formed
and so on so that that's the science
part but the policy component is is very
important and perhaps perhaps the best
what I was most productive not because
of me but I was invited to be part of
PCAST let's because that's the
President's Council of Advisors in
science and technology and that's a
group of 20 scientists we had one
economist also
I was in pikas first with President
Clinton but basically eight years not
with President Bush but then again with
Obama so I was in peak as four
essentially eight years but we were
covering all the science issues
including climate change well but we
work very closely with Obama he liked to
talk to us a lot so it was great we were
very closely so that the Paris agreement
could be implemented it must be signed
on purpose so that we did the US could
join it without asking Congress and you
know why hawkers it because the
Republican Congress is sort of skeptical
policy and we did it it worked except
for what happened recently that we have
to get to undo what it worked
do you know why the whole was like only
on Antarctic antarctica wasn't like not
on the North Pole yes yes that's that's
a good question here's what happens
there is something quite a sec
exceptional about the chemistry that
happens in the atmosphere there normally
those of you that work with chemical
reactions or even just cooking at home
normally when you heat things up at
higher temperatures reactions go faster
but there are some exceptional
situations and one is Antarctica
Antarctica is the coldest place on the
planet and you have a vortex because the
earth of course is spinning so you have
a vortex which is in principle not too
different from the one you get in your
bathtub but that vortex isolates the air
in the winter months when it's dark and
it gets very cold because you don't
because that air is not mixed with air
in other parts why Antarctica well if
you look at our planet it's not
symmetric Antarctica is a continent
which is as is very tall has high
mountains but it's surrounded by all
patience completely so if these four
text becomes really stable what happens
in the Arctic just the opposite you have
a flat ice sheet which by the waist now
it melts in the summer note so you can
have a cruise over the Arctic map which
which is new you couldn't have that
10,000 years ago among other things
because there were no cruises but but
here is what happens visualize the
Arctic it's a flat ocean surrounded by
continent so the vortex is not stable so
it breaks down so it doesn't quite get a
scope so Antarctica gets very cold and
that's why the little bit of water vapor
that is there parts per million levels
can condense and you get very subtle ice
clouds but you can see they they have
fluorescence so if you are in the
southern hemisphere in the winter you
can see these ice clouds from from far
away and they are the ones that
accelerate ozone destruction and so part
of our work in the laboratory and then
with measurements quest to unravel this
chemistry how does ice accelerate these
reactions and if it's now understood
very well but that's a very good
question we understand very well who I
is it over the Arctic that you don't
have an ozone hole although very cold
years you get also also a depletion what
over Antarctica it happens ozone is made
mostly a tropical latitudes but it moves
both ways eventually reaching the balls
so that in short explanation so I wanted
to like mines come like three questions
in one but like okay so basically I
wanted to know like how did you like how
do you pick research like how do you
pick a topic to research research off of
and then like what advice do you give us
give to us youth on picking activities
and stuff like that to research on yes
you have to look around if your students
say first you have to choose what to
link all
fortunately here in the in the United
States and in Europe now to some extent
you can go to college and in the first
few years
you take subject in many different
topics and so you don't really have to
choose as you enter college what you're
going to do because you take some
sciences but you can also take some
social science courses and even some
literature or what have you so you have
more time to choose but keep looking for
the sort of things that you like and
then if you keep going and want to
become a scientist or an engineer or an
economist or what have you the best
advice I have is try to find the sort of
things you like and then find out what's
new what sort of challenges are in there
in that field but once you start doing
research make sure that what you can try
you can try something if you don't like
it try something else it's okay to
change but find the sort of things that
you like most some people like to do
experiment some others like to use
computers some others like to do
experiments on airplanes and
what-have-you
find what you like but then here's a
piece of advice then do it with passion
okay because then you're going to become
very good at it but it has to be
something that you like and be flexible
might take some time to find ok ok so I
read this article that came out years
ago saying that we had 50 years into the
hole in the ozone layer
it's completely closed how many years do
you think that we have let's say did I
understand it correctly exactly it's the
nature of the ozone hole no I said I
read an article that came out years ago
saying that we had 50 years until the
hole was completely closed and I'm
asking now how many years do you think
we have left of working together here's
what's happening well as I try to
explain briefly first the the ozone hole
is those of you in the sciences it
nonlinear effect because it has to do
with some reactions of chlorine radicals
with themselves so in simple terms it
goes with the square of the of the
concentration of the decomposition
products from CFCs so that just means
that when we first started worrying
about it it wasn't there and it sort of
suddenly appeared and what's happening
now is that because we still have a lot
of CFCs that were emitted last century
it their concentration is only slowly
decreasing and it's now at scuse me at
the stage where some years you can see
that the ozone hole is no longer there
and some other still comes up because
you have a lot of fluctuations but there
are clear indications that it's no
longer as stable as it has been for the
last decade or two okay so that means
that something is happening and of
course we know that the concentration of
the CFCs has gone down as expected they
have not it hasn't gone down to zero
because of this long lifetime but it has
gone down exactly as predicted because
we know how long it takes for them to
get to sufficiently high altitudes to be
destroyed by by solar very short
wavelength solar radiation but short
wavelength all probably that breaks also
molecular oxygen that's how you get a
Tomic oxygen and that's how you make
also okay so in in a nutshell you have
to admit that there are all sorts of
changes from year to year changes have
to do with the climate that it doesn't
change smoothly
but considering those changes the
observations very clearly indicate that
it is already healing and we need to
probably wait another decade or two
before you see a really very big change
and it's going back to normal
with there are some caveats I just
mentioned one climate change the fact
you you
changing the composition of the
atmosphere that means that you're
changing the climate so it's actually
getting warmer down here but it's
getting colder in the stratosphere
that's what you would expect if you do
the energy balances and that means that
you're going to be lay the covering of
the ozone layer because of climate
change how much it depends of whether we
tackle the the emission of carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gases
coming from burning fossil fuels if we
do that then then it will recover soon I
wanted to know how exactly the CFC is
affected the ozone layer so what how
exactly did CFCs ozone okay
here here is what happens I didn't
explain that in any detail but the CFCs
were invented as miracle chemicals to
replace refrigerants that we'll use at
the beginning of last century when when
when electric refrigerators were first
invented that was early in the century
okay timber 1910 and so all 1920 and
they used refrigerants that were sort of
very worrisome some of you might have
handled these gases but the main
refrigerants were sold for dioxide any
of you have smelled that no or ammonia
perhaps some of you have smelled that
okay what imagine a refrigerator like
that breaking down and if you have it in
your in your living room and you're
sitting there that that can be even
dangerous not only smells very bad but
if you cannot move away fast enough
it can affect your health quite
dramatically that's why it was a very
big success to find chemicals that you
could use instead of these nasty
chemicals and one proof that they work
is that you could
use them also in spray cans imagine
using a spray can with ammonia you I
mean you just couldn't think of that
okay so spray cans only became available
they were used with hydrocarbons to some
extent but they became readily available
when these miracle chemicals the
chlorofluorocarbons or CFCs were
invented and that's why they were used
all over the place
large amounts but it was after all just
an industrial chemicals so forth people
thought that you you just shouldn't
worry about them
yeah because mixed in the entire
atmosphere the concentrations were in
measure that parts per trillion levels
very small amounts and very stable
chemicals that you can breathe why worry
but that's why we decided to find out
where will they be destroyed and with
something else happened so we found out
they would be destroyed at high
altitudes just like oxygen itself when
if you move enough above the normal
atmosphere then you get this very short
wavelength radiation that breaks
everything eventually you can even break
atoms okay and ionize them but you break
molecules long before that and you can
break the oxygen molecule and that's how
awesome is made and the same wavelengths
break the CFC molecule so that's what we
found but then we went further what
happens to the decomposition product and
because the CFCs are made from halogens
and like CFC L 3 is a formula for one of
them is a derivative of methane you get
free chlorine atoms and there are free
radicals okay radicals in the sense of
chemicals and lot of people because
there are some radicals free radicals
are species that have an odd number of
electrons and they react very fast so
they happen to react with ozone in a
very peculiar way because one atom of
chlorine destroys and also molecule and
then with subsequent reactions I don't
have time to explain that you recover
the chlorine atom so a single
Adam can destroy thousands tens of
thousands of also molecules that's what
we call catalysis which is important in
chemical engineering many industrial
chemicals are made with catalysts so the
point is at the very small amount of
these chemicals you can have a very
large effect on the ozone layer and
that's how we came about this idea that
that the ozone layer was gonna be
affected and that was indeed what came
out from measurements so that's the idea
how was the whole affecting wildlife
populations in it in Antarctica okay not
Arctic at the main effect of the but
when you have this awesome whole is in
in the the oceans surrounding Antarctica
because you have a lot it's very active
even at those very low temperatures the
water if it's like with it it's close to
zero degrees in although it's salty
water so it's a little lower than that
but you have a lot of algae and you have
a lot of active living species there and
those are the ones some of those are
being affected and that has been
measured as well okay fortunately we're
not able to stop that if hasn't had any
major consequences but it those are
measurable but there is a worry even on
human populations and that are close to
the when the whole moves around a little
bit sometimes you get this high
ultraviolet radiation in in the southern
hemisphere Australians were very worried
about that and I you know something
changed in Australia because they
weren't people that they could not be
exposed to the Sun without worrying
about it so the Australians were to use
hats when they go to the beach and
clothes that were not transparent to
ultraviolet so the Australians did
change because the incidence of skin
cancer was changing but I'm I'm most at
this
it's quite interesting what I'll be very
fast you know that people with dark skin
they evolve mostly closer to the tropics
and people with very light skin at much
higher latitudes why well because close
to the tropics RT also layers thinner
you get more ultraviolet radiation and
if your dark skin you are not so
susceptible to skin cancer
that's way we evolved but what happens
in Australia Australia's quite a bit
south and the Australians didn't evolve
there you know where they came from
mostly from England ok so you have these
very light-skinned people suddenly
moving to latitudes where you have
worrisome incidence of light so that was
the first main reason why they have to
worry about this if in addition you
start depleting the ozone layer then it
affects them more but that has been a
well-recognized problem people light
skin moving to latitudes where normally
you get a lot more sunshine that's why
it's not wise to be exposed to the Sun
without protection and that's why you
have all sorts of dreams SPF 30 50
wherever that's to stop the ultraviolet
radiation from from harming you that's
part of it all right so I have good news
and I have bad news the bad news is I
can only take one more question but the
good news is that after this I need
everyone to come down through those
steps because we have 3m goody bags
[Laughter]
so we can ask the last question now I
want to give it to one other person
after I'm done doing it I hope I could
fit this question in between that yeah
my question is uh like you know how the
axis the axis I heard in a science
lecture that the axis of the earth is
moving kind of like of our planet you
mean yeah okay and then they're like
related to the Oh
how does that connect the global born
okay let me see if I understood the
question but it's a very interesting one
the it it's actually the answer to the
question why do we have ice ages it's
not connected to global warming
very clearly but I'll explain you first
what happens is our planet of course has
a tilted axis and it has a p-orbital
around the Sun it's elliptical but if
you look in great detail why this
happens it's influenced by gravity and
by other planets that sometimes come
close and so on so it turns out that you
can calculate that there is what we call
periodicities every ten thousand
probably ten thousand every forty
thousand years the geometrical aspects
change and you get the orbit to change
its ellipticity but you get also the
axis because it's it's it's moving
around okay and when the axis and they
are the orbit changes in certain ways
you get sufficiently less some solar
radiation directly hitting the planet as
it normally does that you get ice ages
and how is that tested because you can
calculate from physical laws as
essentially just classical physics how
often should this change and that has
been done by planetary science
is extremely carefully and the
periodicities coincide very well with
those that you measure with with by
geologists that know exactly when the
ice ages came about and so on the
interesting thing about that is that
that's not quite enough to explain the
big climate change but if you have
feedback from carbon dioxide that if you
cool a little bit it begins to condense
so you could you pull more and if you
warm up then there's more co2 than you
warm up more so that explains the ice
ages but this all these things happened
very slowly
10,000 40,000 years or so so climate
change that we're looking at it's a
matter of few decades okay so all these
explanations do not function for climate
change so one of the big characteristics
of climate change that is very well
understood and so on is that we're
changing the climate at the speed that
is not natural okay it hasn't changed at
first in geological large geological
timescales so that's part of the of the
reason I'm not sure I was answering the
same questions you are asking but anyhow
it's a very interesting point I hope
that's what you were asking about it
it's the geometry of the of the orbits
all right so as I said that does
conclude our night thank you all for
coming
[Applause]
[Music]